all right we're on problem 17 it says
which of the following best describes
the triangles
shown below
triangle shown below both are okay they
want to know are they similar are they
congruent et cetera et cetera okay
so let's think about it a little bit
they tell us that this is a 60 degree
angle this is a 90 degree angle right
they do this little square thing there
that tells us 90 degree angle
the angles in a triangle have to add up
to 180 so this is 90 this is 60 that
adds up to 150
so this has to be 180 minus 150 so this
has to be a 30 degree angle
so that has to be 30 degrees right there
fair enough now let's get this one
that's 30 that's 90. well by the same
argument this has got to be 60 because
they all have to add up to 180.
all right so just there we know that all
of the angles in both of the triangles
are
congruent or that their measures are
equal so we know already that these are
definitely both similar triangles
similar triangles
now a similar triangle also tells us
that
the ratio of all of the sides are equal
so you know if you just were to eyeball
it if you said okay the side opposite
the 90 degree these are the
corresponding sides the ratios are equal
but we see that they give us the actual
length the hypotenuse of both of these
triangles are is eight so the ratio is
actually one to one and when the ratio
of the sides is one to one where the
sides are actually congruent and if
you're just given one side that's enough
then you could actually figure out the
rest of them using well you could use a
little trigonometry or something like
that we're not going to go there just
yet but in geometry class you learn that
if something is similar and two of the
corresponding sides or at least one of
the corresponding sides is congruent
then the whole thing is going to be
congruent so these are
both similar and congruent
triangles
similar and congruent triangles both
similar and congruent that's a
problem 18
problem 18.
okay let me cut and paste it
okay
which of the following statements must
be true if triangle ghi is similar so
when they just write a curly thing like
that without so if they write this that
means congruent if they just write that
that means similar
which of the following statements must
be true if triangle ghi is similar to
triangle j k l so even before looking at
the choices that means that the ratio of
all of the sides are the same or all of
the angles are the same let's see what
they give us
the two triangles must be scaling now
you can have similar triangles that are
isosceles or equilateral that's not
right
the two triangles must have exactly one
acute angle the two triangles must have
exactly one acute angle
exact must have exactly one acute angle
no they could have two acute angles they
could have three acute and i mean the
way that they've drawn here actually all
of them are cute there's none of these
angles are greater than 90 degrees just
the way they've drawn so that's not
right
some of these statements are so crazy
that that they're hard to process anyway
see at least one of the sides of the two
triangles
must be parallel
well i don't care how they're oriented
at least one of the sides of the two
triangles must i don't know
you don't care about the orientation of
the triangles
the corresponding sides of the two
triangles must be proportional yeah
that's one of the that's one of the ways
that you know that something is similar
is that the corresponding sides are
proportional so that is d so this is
almost you know do you know the
definition of a similar triangle
question 19.
let me erase this
okay
i have
copied it
and now i am
pasting it
in the figure below
ac
is congruent to df okay so they're equal
to each other ac and df are congruent
and angle a is congruent to angle d
and angle a
is congruent to angle d
fair enough that's angle a that's angle
d that's what they tell us
which additional information would be
enough to prove that triangle
a b c a
a b c is congruent to d e f
so they just gave us one side and one
angle if they gave us another side if
they said that d e is congruent to a b
that'd be pretty cool
if they gave us
if they gave us this angle if they said
angle f is congruent to angle c that'd
be good let's see what they give us
a b is congruent to d e
yeah sure if a b
is congruent to d e
then we definitely have congruent
triangles
and you know the the theorem that you
would have to say in your geometry class
is oh i have a side an angle and a side
so you would say by sas
by side angle side i know that these two
triangles are
congruent so a b is congruent to d let's
look at the other ones just so we didn't
miss anything a b is congruent to bc
a
b
is congruent to bc well that's fine but
that doesn't tell us how a b relates to
d e so that's a useless statement
b c is congruent to e f
b c is congruent to ef
we see this is another time that i have
a slight problem with the way they're
going with this because
if bc were congruent to ef
if this were true bc work work congruent
to ef
let me think about that could i draw
this triangle in a way where they're
still not congruent because i have this
angle here constraining it right they
told us that that's so it's not like i
can draw this line this fe line it's not
like i can draw it coming out here
right
because if i came out here then d e
would have to come like that
and then
this angle couldn't be what it said it
they said it was so i'm just trying to
think i actually think that would be
sufficient
that would be sufficient if you're given
that
if you're given that those that this
side is congruent to that side i think
you could make a trigonometric
trigonometric argument very easily to
show that these two triangles have equal
sides but anyway i'm not going to bother
with them again let's see let's look at
choice d bc is congruent to d e
b c is congruent to
d e well these aren't even corresponding
sides so that's clearly useless
i have a suspicion that this would have
also been enough to prove but anyway
i i've already
i'm i'm slightly i you know i i don't
want to insult anyone in the california
department of education but i'm slightly
disappointed by some of these questions
because i feel like
they really aren't testing intuition
they're just testing to see whether you
know the definitions of some of these
geometric terms and whether you can
spout out you know side angle side angle
side angle and things like that and
you're going to forget those about
three hours after you take the test
and that's pretty useless what's useful
is if you know something that gives you
an intuition about triangles that's
going to be useful for you on the sat
that's going to be useful for you when
you take the essay when you take
trigonometry and i'll tell you a dirty
secret you will never see
you you will never use you know asa
theorem or sas theorem or anything like
that again in your mathematical careers
your your 9th or 10th grade geometry
class is the first and the last time
that you'll ever see them so i have a
slight problem where they're
where they want you to you know memorize
these these theorems and all of that and
even some of this notation never shows
up again in your in your mathematical
careers even if you do a phd in
mathematics the only time you'll
probably see it again is if you become a
geometry math teacher anyway
but it's good i mean you you should know
how to do this stuff at minimum just to
jump through the hoop that society makes
us all jump through so problem 20
problem 20. you don't want someone else
to get paid more just because they were
willing to say sas asa anyway all right
problem 20. given a b and c d intersect
at point e all right right a b and c d
intersect at point e and just another
side i think you you can even tell from
my tone that i enjoy the sat problems a
lot more because in some ways and in
fact in every way the sat problems
really test your understanding of
geometry but never do they mention the
words similar congruent sas asa they
never mention all of these things that
you essentially memorize in your
geometry class and i know tons of people
who get a's in geometry and then they
they don't do well on the s.a.t i know
people who do the other way and frankly
i'd rather hire the person who does well
on the sat because that's the person who
i think has the intuition but anyway we
have to do this and i'm
i probably shouldn't rant like that
see given a b and c d intersect at point
e
angle one
okay given that a b and c d intersected
point a fair enough and they tell us
that angle one is congruent to angle two
so angle one
so that
and that are equal
all right so already that those look
like alternate interior angles if this
line were parallel in fact i think
that's enough to show that this line is
parallel to this line
right
that those two are parallel because if
you view this as a transversal if you
view dc as a transversal then you see
that that's a transversal between these
two lines
and because the alternate interior
angles are the same or they're congruent
you know that those are going to be
parallel lines but anyway i don't know
if that's at all useful
what are they going to ask us which
theorem or postulate can be used to
prove that aed
aed
that aed
is similar to bec
okay so let's see similar so i didn't
have to even say that those are parallel
lines
so if we know that so what do they tell
us at the bot they intersect at point a
angle one is complete okay so first of
all we know that three and four
are
congruent angles because they're
opposite angles
once again i don't like the word
vertical angles because these angles are
clearly not vertical they're more side
by side but they're definitely opposite
so those two angles are the same
if these two angles so
these two angles sorry one and two are
the same three and four are the same
they you know all if you know two of the
angles in a triangle you know the third
so this angle and that angle have to be
the same but in general if you know that
two angles of a triangle the same the
third has to be the same so
that tells you that it's a similar
triangle so we could use angle angle we
know that two angles are same as two
other angles so we know we're dealing
with similar triangles
anyway all out of time because of my my
rant see you in the next video